a five member technical team from Guyana
has successfully completed the
infrastructure for the national
agriculture Innovation and Technology
Center marking a significant step
forward in St Lucia's drive for
agricultural modernization the project a
product of the collaboration between the
government of St Lucia and Guyana for
agricultural technology adaptation and
Innovation features two tunnel green
houses equipped with a nutrient fi
technique hydroponic system the
initiative is set to revolutionize St
Lucia's agricultural sector by
integrating sustainable practices with
cuttingedge hydroponic technology the
system offers a more efficient approach
to farming particularly beneficial in
combating challenges posed by the dry
season Hydroponics reduces water and
fertilizer waste while ensuring optimal
crop growth making it an environment Al
friendly and cost effective alternative
to traditional farming the hydroponic
system an ideal solution for Farmers
with limited land space allowing them to
maximize productivity in small areas
with the completion of this facility the
Ministry of Agriculture now has a
powerful tool to educate and showcase to
the local farmers the tangible benefits
of Hydroponics farming lead Hydroponics
technician khil Benjamin emphasize that
this Innovation is expected to improve
food security and economic resilience
within the agricultural sector by using
less water and fertilizer while yielding
higher productivity yeah so today uh we
finished the project uh the two B tunnel
houses are completed and with the
hydroponic system um this will be of a
great benefit to the St Luan people
right um hydroponic it's uh not a new
technique it has been over here for 2 to
3,000 years it's a very old technology
but uh what we did was we refined the
the the the the technique and we did it
it's called Precision agriculture
because what we're doing we're not
wasting fertilizers right we're not
wasting fertilizers we're not wasting
water especially right in in a system
like if you have a say we have an area
like as we have 32 by 100 ft you may use
about 450 gallons of water per day right
on on your crop uh with this hydroponic
system you use that actually every 3
weeks right so so when we go we know we
have have dry periods to go into so that
can be a great benefit for the farmers
so you can always have no short of
production through that system the two
tunnel green houses have a combined
capacity of growing over 2,600 plants
with one Greenhouse supporting
1,425 plants and the other
1,200 this advancement signifies a
transformative step towards modern
technology driven farming in St Lua
fostering increased efficiency
sustainability and resilience in food
production this what we have here today
is a nft system so n is called a
nutrient film technique which just means
a tin film of water is running on the
root of the plant right the system is a
recyclable system so it's goes from uh
30 ft in length and it comes back up
again on a pump right we also have a
AirStone to create oxygen for the system
so everything is in place every
parameters is in place and checked we
also have filters on the system to to
ensure that there's no uh clogging or
anything that happens to the system so
you need to maintain that as well right
so we have a today we have the school
kids so we want to do an introduction
with them too as well the successful
completion of this initiative highlights
the strengthening of agricultural ties
between St Lucia and Guyana showcasing
Regional cooporation in the adoption of
advanced farming Technologies as the fa
faity becomes operational it is expected
to serve as a model for the future of
agriculture in the region empowering
local farmers with Innovative techniques
to enhance food production and
sustainability from the Ministry of
Agriculture Fisheries food security
andural development I am Zar fix
reporting